well i think the general's right the
lacks a general strategy that's going to
achieve this if anyone thinks that by
bombing alone we are going to defeat
isis they're sadly mistaken there need
to be boots on the ground and whose
boots are they going to be because the
kurds will fight very bravely and have
fought very bravely to the edge of their
territory but who is going to fall i
think there's a general view they're not
going to be british or american boots
there needs to be no inclination in
western countries to anywhere to send
forces to do this so we mean we need
other people's forces and who are they
going to be say the kurds won't go into
the sunni areas the shia has shown no
ability to go into the sunni areas of
iraq and even if they did who's going to
fight in syria as the general was saying
the fsa is tiny the three syrian army is
tiny and they're going to be fighting
assad not fighting isis so who is
actually going to do this fighting well
i'm interviewing you i mean who are you
who are you suggesting well i think you
need to get sunny fighters the most
obvious way to do it would be to go back
to the anbar awakening that we had when
we were in iraq where the americans
managed to get the sunni tribes to rise
up against the predecessor of isis and
fight al-qaeda in iraq very successfully
we need that sort of strategy again but
we don't have it so do we need saudi
arabians do we need other gulf forces do
we need as the general saying the turks
i'd be very surprised if the turks
actually go into syria and if they did
they would probably be fighting the
kurds rather than fighting the isis in
those circumstances nor do i think given
the current war in yemen it's very
likely that we'll see saudi and other
forces in syria now i don't think that's
very likely i think we need to have
homegrown sunni forces in iraq and
homegrown sunni forces in syria to do
that and more than that i think we
actually need a political strategy and i
think in a way that's what's most
lacking it's not just a military
strategy but this is going to work we
have to have a political strategy but
meanwhile as the general says the
islamic state is consolidating and to a
certain extent those people in the
theater
who are not prepared to take it on look
a bit like fellow travelers don't they
without putting it too crudely well yes
but i think the real problem is we have
to look at why
isis or daesh are being so successful
what is it that's underpinning their
success and in the end it is the support
that they get from sunnis in iraq and in
syria who feel disenfranchised they feel
that they were left with a malaki
sectarian sheer government in baghdad
that was exploiting them
how else could a thousand
isis fighters take over a city the size
of mosul they could only do that a
million people they could only do that
if there was some support for them and
unless we addressed that if the army ran
away didn't it the army ran away and
there's a large part of the public run
away subsequently but there was no
resistance from the public to isis
coming in because they saw the maliki
government as being so evil so difficult
for them they could actually perform so
they'd prefer the sort of things that
we're seeing now so you're saying that
the people on the ground prepare the
beheadings and the chucking gaze off
buildings and drowning people and
setting fire to them and forced
marriages and uh
suicide bombing you saying that's what
the local people actually want no doubt
that the majority of people hate all of
that stuff on the other hand they quite
like being provided with bread having
some way of living have some sort of
stability and above all they don't want
to have those things happening to them
from a government based in baghdad that
we left in charge of baghdad without
allowing any proper dialogue so you're
saying you think that people actually
prefer is i think that people certainly
preferred is when it comes to what they
had said government or to the maliki
government in iraq and as we addressed
that issue of how are we going to
reconcile sunnis if you look at who the
number twos in the isis organization are
so after mr al-baghdadi nearly all of
them as far as we know them are
extradite military people they're not
suddenly discovered are loving for a
caliphate what they want to do is attack
shia